hey anne how are you i'm well how are
you i'm doing well you are so
good in this before we get into the
series and how good you are is rebecca
um i think it's been proven
that you know the office workspace isn't
for everyone so i was curious have you
ever worked in an office and were you
any good at it
i did work in an office sort of uh when
i was prepping for my role in the
deborah's prada um i worked for a few
weeks at sotheby's no christie's whoops
um clearly i wasn't that good at it
because i didn't know where i worked but
it was a minute ago
um and i thought i was i thought it was
okay you know they were so kind to just
let me go in and observe and there
wasn't anything
much for me to do given that that wasn't
my area of expertise so i made myself
useful um i i kind of re-cataloged their
library i noticed that things were out
of order so i um yeah so i guess i just
made myself into a librarian
which uh which
which um i think made me okay at an
office i think i'm i'm pleasant and keep
to myself and hopefully contribute to
the overall environment
and you sound organized so people love
working with organized people
i am i i i you know i've always been
fairly organized as an actress and it's
taken me a minute to bring that level up
in my life as well you know how it is
when like oh yeah you know how it is
that's amazing so it was so much fun
watching you transform into rebecca
newman especially when it comes to your
voice what were certain rebecca
mannerisms that you wanted to get just
right
that is a great question um
i started doing yoga to better
understand her because it was so
important to her
and i noticed you know when people seem
very serious about yoga they have a
certain way of
of carrying themselves um
and i know that there's an answer to
this question but for the life of me i
cannot think of what those things are
but the the
so i'm really sorry it was a minute ago
and i played um i played two characters
since then
so um
but the voice was very important to get
right it was a way into her
but um
so much of the details of her life
mattered to me
you know like uh
while i was kind of getting to know
everybody i was trying to and it felt
like i just felt like i was kind of
insane but i said it's really important
that we show that she would have a
certain type of napkin you know the
clothes that she wear would be of a
certain level and so i was kind of
always pushing for that so um i felt
like it was a little bit of the d i'm a
little flush talking about it because
it's a little embarrassing but i was
kind of the detail devil on this one and
i felt because that's where i felt like
she lived
well it comes across in this series
because we are just completely uh you
know invested in this character now we
know that jared leto was definitely a
method actor from what i understand he
was in character as adam from day one on
set so what was it like working with him
yeah i don't know if it's if it's method
but it's definitely immersive
and oh it was so wonderful
it was so wonderful and i was so
inspired um
that he takes what we do as seriously as
he does and that he's so committed to it
um
he was always so sweet with me and so
gentle and he cared about my performance
so much and was so generous and
we were just very free with each other
and fearless and it just felt it really
felt like
um
we were
it really felt like we were getting into
the partnership that adam and rebecca
had and that was a really enjoyable
experience
is it wild to think that you were the
one to present jared with his oscar in
2014 did this feel a bit like a full
circle moment working so closely with
him on this series
it did it did we didn't really you know
i didn't want to talk too much about the
world outside of what we were doing uh
with him just out of respect for his
process
but um
but it did come up once or twice and and
it was it's a he had a nice
synchronicity
how often do you see
that amazing photobomb photo of you at
the vanity fair
party with him behind you and his oscar
and then you turning around and looking
so surprised to see him
i was so surprised it was my first time
getting photobombed and um
and knowing no and now having worked
with him and knowing how playful he can
be it just it warms my heart even more
what is it about uh a story about a rise
and fall that is so fascinating to us
because i couldn't get enough of this
series um i'm glad to hear you say that
and um
i'm not sure maybe it's us trying to put
ourselves in it maybe it's just our
i personally find charismatic leaders to
be really really fascinating
and um and that was part of the draw for
me but but but one of the things that i
think is also really interesting about
this story in particular and and
something that we're seeing repeated uh
right now with a lot of these kind of
startup entrepreneurial stories is this
whole idea of
fake it till you make it
and it's something that i think we all
do a version of
and in some of these cases certainly in
the case of this story it was taken to
such an extreme as to become untenable
and i'm really interested in where that
line is and what makes people
hold so clearly to that idea that if i
can just make it true it doesn't matter
how i got here
yeah that's such a good point and then
convincing so many people that you're
the real deal
and having the charisma to convince
people that you're the real deal and
what if you mean to be the real deal
like that's the part that's the thing is
i don't think that it's so cut and dry
as to say
someone is fraud well sometimes it is
sometimes it is
um but but but sometimes i'm really
fascinated by people
who
who mean for the things that they say to
be true the thing that one of the things
that um
really made me want to take part in this
series was i watched the firefest
documentary yeah and i was watching that
and i just couldn't i just said he he
means everything that he says he's just
living in a different reality than the
rest of us but every word that's coming
out of his mouth i believe he he
believes yeah and i was fascinated by
that yeah that is fascinating um you
know there's so much that we're learning
about wework and and you know the highs
and the lows when you're watching this
series but at the heart of it it really
is this love story why is it so
important to showcase the relationship
um in terms of telling the story
properly
because it exists and because it's real
and because i think that if you were to
ask anyone and i did
they would say that without
without rebecca there was no adam
and um
and and without adam there would have
been rebecca would have been a very very
different person
and i think that and there you know
obviously there are our series is based
on a podcast and there have been
multiple books about wework and there's
now been a documentary
and people have kind of looked into the
business side of things but there hasn't
been as much attention paid to the two
human beings at the center of this story
and that was the opportunity that that
was available to us so we took it yeah
and it really humanizes these characters
too like you you like i said you feel
emotionally connected to them
i'm glad to hear you say that we took
that very very seriously it was very
important to us to not judge them but to
just see them just recognize that we
were human beings telling the story of
other human beings yeah um it's such a
great moment a few times in this series
where you hear katy perry's roar which
feels like kind of the theme to this
series but it's definitely the pump up
song for jared's character adam what
would you say is your pump up song
my pump up song yeah oh formation by
beyonce oh so good and when do you play
that when do you need to hear that
um
at the gym when i don't want to do
whatever it is that i'm about to do
and i'm just like it's the perf the song
is the perfect length and it just gets
you into that zone right away and you
put it on and for that two and a half
minutes you can you're invincible you
can do anything i was just gonna say you
feel like you can do anything
yeah i know it's such a good song did
you take anything
from set or anything that reminded you
of this character i mean because unlike
a film and of course you spent a lot of
time uh
embodying a character in film but this
is a series and there's so much to this
did you take anything from set
i took a crystal
oh i love it any kind of crystal
i'm not sure i'm not sure what kind it
is just really pretty and i put it in my
bag on the last day
oh my gosh i love that um
when you do it felt very on brand for
both of us
[Applause]
i was just gonna say i love that
um
when you do a project like this who are
you excited uh to show who's the first
person that you can't wait to show your
work to
i never think about it on those terms i
i mean truly i i really i'm i'm never
thinking about uh that aspect of it i'm
so kind of
lost in the in the making of it i am
relieved when my husband sees it if he
likes it because he's he always keeps it
real he always keeps it 100 loving but
he he keeps it real with me
and um
i was so i was nervous when he saw this
one but he he called me up and he was
like no it's you guys you guys nailed
you did it was really good he was really
he's like i think i think people are
really gonna respond to this it's really
strong he's not lying it's so
so well done so congratulations yeah
thank you very very much so nice talking
to you
[Laughter]
you